so leute das gab es ja noch nie auf dem
kanal ich mache ja sonst nicht so
typische youtube format aber heute mal
ein follow me round den morgen gibt es
den live stream zu 50 jahre mondlandung
50 jahre exakt nach der mondlandung leid
von allem was damals passiert ist mit
den vielen infos die heute dazu gekommen
sind
hier mal ein dass ihr übrigens also da
sieht sich jetzt weiß ich nicht damit
rmh 70 grade und schneide ein interview
noch hier mit ein und ewald astronaut
der wirklich super spannende sachen
erzählt dass dann morgen in betrieben ab
21 of tricks und hier kommen wir jetzt
ins studio quasi so hier sind philippe
und vince die gerade aufbauen und wir
haben uns ein kleines setzte zusammen
gebaut in dem wir dann die ganze sendung
morgen machen und ja erst mal ganz viele
ich muss mir hier so ein bisschen gucken
wir mal ganz viele requisiten haben wir
zusammengestellt die zeigen und
bebildern und illustrieren wie damals
die mondlandung so ausgesehen hat und
jetzt ja sie sieht lichtstimmung schon
ein bisschen her sei es auch im
astronauten stehen und natürlich technik
die es damals sogar die musikkassette
war ja gerade erfunden worden also 21
uhr krieg so was was kann sich noch
zeigen was das wasser im moment moment
moment hier
das ist auch wirklich wahnsinn das hat
er gemacht ja eine tischdecke auch im
mode design dann habe auch noch eine 1 1
ratequiz wo es tolle preise zu gewinnen
gibt und übrigens seit unbedingt dabei
kommentiert das stellt uns fragen und
wir gucken dass wir sie beantworten und
vielleicht wartet man sie auch unsere
astronauten die wir im vorfeld
interviewt haben
da gibt es unendlich wie krebs mit
unglaublich vielen tollen
insiderinformationen wie weltraum hat
heute so aussieht und eine frage gibt es
die würde es uns auch beschäftigen und
zwar zusammen mit michael lettmann
betritt der erste die erste deutsche den
mond dazu auch mehr infos und
allerding bei breaking app dafür hier
klicken
also klicken anschauen und abonnieren
und natürlich den live stream sehen den
krieg der hier also 20 der juli 21 uhr
seid dabei bis dann bleibt dran